[Music]
foreign
models workshop at our conference now it
says advanced in the title you don't
need to be an expert to join us if
you're taking the introductory uh Teddy
models Workshop you'd be in a really
good position to join us but if you
haven't if you've ever used 20 miles
before you'll probably be in good shape
so if you fit a parsnip model or
resampled it or if you've used a recipe
things like that you'll probably be in a
good position to uh to understand what
we're going to go through now what are
we going to talk about the problem
so one thing we'll talk about is
Advanced recipe usage so recipes are
like preprocessors for your data before
you put them in the model and we'll talk
about some sort of like Pro tips for
using recipes as well as how to optimize
them
the second thing we'll talk about is
model tuning so you have models and some
tuning parameters we'll look at things
like grid search iterative search it's
cool things called racing methods that
you can use to optimize your model
performance
and then the third thing we'll talk
about is calibration so after you fit
your model you want to make sure that
your classification probabilities or
your fitted regression predictions are
super consistent with the data that you
built the model on so we have some new
tools for that that we think are really
cool so anyway we hope to see you in
person in Chicago I especially hope to
see you at the advancing Mouse Workshop
thanks a lot
[Music]